ah  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  all right so my friend sergio was like  yo bros you guys look like you need some  hawks to play around with for a little  while i'm like yeah we do  and  turns out they're like hoverboards um  but unfortunately the wheel has not been  replaced yet as the ultimate mode of  transportation we're about to go tear it  up in little tokyo  [Music]  number one thing i've learned while  writing the idahoque  because the ladies love the iowa  [Music]  are you bike laned  [Music]  that's how you hide a hawk these will go  for 12 miles before you recharge it  again  12 miles  [Applause]  [Music]  let's see what magneto feels like  [Music]  we'll all just eat whatever cheesecake  for every meal we'll ride these  everywhere and we'll be like get like  superheroes  [Music]  away  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you